we're just having some breaking news now
that a separatist leader in don yensk in
eastern ukraine has announced the
evacuation of civilians
to russia now we missed the start of
your answer there so i'm going to ask it
again what's the significance of this
announcement can you break it all down
for us in the context of the ukraine and
russia crisis
well this is hugely significant yes an
announcement from the leader of the
self-declared donetsk people's republic
dennis buschillin announcing an
evacuation of people on the separatist
control side
um to russia to in the area of rostov in
russia dennis was shilling saying that
the first stage of this evacuation would
be for women children and the elderly
and
not to put two finer points on it he
said that
this was in the interests of saving
lives of course this is significant
because we've heard rumors of this being
potentially announced over in the last
sort of 12 12 hours or so it was
initially denied by the separatist
leadership it now seems to be happening
and what it would imply would be
potentially
some sort of
some sort of major escalation military
escalation in this region now of course
michelin is talking about civilians on
the separatist controlled side of the
line of control
there are
potentially millions of people on this
side of the ukrainian government
controlled side that of course if there
was to be some sort of military
escalation some sort of move then these
people are very much at risk
we've heard time and time again that
russia has no interest
in invading ukraine but we've also had a
lot of fear from ukraine and its western
backers of what it describes as what
they describe as false flag operations
these are would be falsified incidents
manufactured to give some sort of
pretext to the separatists and possibly
their russian backers to launch some
sort of military escalation so this
announcement from dennis chilean saying
that this evacuation of civilians in
that area and that's a that's a very
large area as well the contact line is
around 420 kilometers long that snakes
up from southeast ukraine and heading
north
that is going to involve potentially a
lot of people so a very worrying sign of
what can only imply some sort of
military decision that may have been
taken but of course we cannot confirm
that all we can confirm is that the
announcement for this evacuation has
happened
all right charles stay with us because
russian president vladimir putin is
speaking so we're going to try and cross
to that shortly but in the meantime i
just want to talk to you a little bit
about the context of all of this we've
been speaking to you about it throughout
the day you've been saying where you are
is relatively quiet but
as we've been reporting russian-backed
separatists and government forces in
donbass have accused each other of
launching new attacks so what does this
mean in terms of the escalation of this
conflict
well ukraine has described the shelling
in the last couple of days as as being
an
escalation um some people describing it
as the worst escalation
since the end of um
hostilities in 2015 when a ceasefire was
signed and a ceasefire that has failed
dramatically to keep both sides from
sporadically shelling each other
sporadic shelling happens along the
contacts line
almost every day and has done for years
but of course it has huge implications
for the safety of the people in this
area um fourteen thousand people killed
already in the eight years of this
conflict three thousand of which are
civilians uh the u.n estimates that
around three million people in this
region in this year charles i'm going to
have to interrupt you there because we
are going to try and go to the russian
president apologies but we have
translation now so let's go to the
russian president vladimir putin who's
speaking in moscow alongside the balor
russian presidential and the building of
the union state
we
discussed in detail the uh the progress
and the implementation of agreements
that we signed in 2021
and how the 28
sectoral programs are being implemented
and we noted that these 28 programs
is nothing but a continuation of
our bilateral cooperation and
integration that we agreed earlier
we also noted that our ministries and
agencies um are working productively in
every field of integration
the high level group for coordinating
integration is working well
and will meet again
has already met in november
close contacts are maintained by the
governments
the prime ministers
met eight times
last year they are regularly in contact
almost weekly
are personally monitoring the
implementation of agreements
to do with integration
we could identify a number of
integration fields where we have had
real progress
transport and logistics
the transit of many
categories of belarusian goods has in
two third countries through russia has
increased notably
and we're working towards
integrating our carriers
we also are working
to mitigate the illegitimate sanctions
taken against our countries
aimed at
making the economic situation more
difficult in our countries
we're also working in fields like
integrating the payment systems to
create a single payment space
integrating the customs
and employment law
join up
the gas and the energy markets
all our joint efforts to
implement the union state agenda
economically
is aimed at securing growth and
increasing the living standards of
our citizens
our other large-scale integration
projects are also
facing a
great prospect the eurasian economic
union
and
to create a single employment market
all eurasian union countries are
receiving great benefits from these
integration processes at today's talks
we also discussed
strengthening our joint defense space of
russia and belarus we agreed again
to take collective measures to secure
to strengthen security of our countries
in the face of the growing military
activity of nato countries on the
borders of our union state near the
borders
we also focused on the
in this context focused on the exercises
called allied resolve which will
continue until the 20th of february in
belarus
i should say that these exercises are
totally defensive in nature and do not
threaten anyone the defense ministries
of both countries notified
everybody about these planned maneuvers
well in advance
and during these exercises as i informed
mr lukashenka
many
military attaches from the foreign
countries were invited and visited and
could see for their for themselves
at president lukashenka's request i
shared the content of my recent contacts
with the foreign leaders
devoted to the topic of providing
long-term and legally binding security
guarantees to russia
and i believe that understandably this
concerns our belarusian
allies
we discussed the situation concerning
progress of russia's demands to the west
the main watch of win is the
non-expansion of nato
giving up strike weapons deployments of
strike weapons near russian borders and
returning to
the
pre-1997 position
when
the nato russia founding act was
signed unfortunately other members the
members of the alliance are not prepared
to accept our initiatives
at the same time we
formulated ideas um on
military transparency
formulated ideas of military
transparency
which we are not against and we are
prepared to follow the negotiating track
as long as all issues are considered
together
and not giving up those that are our
priority
mr lukashenko and i discussed
the problem around the ukrainian the
inter intra-ukrainian conflict um the
implementation of the minsk agreement is
delayed again despite our joint efforts
and contacts at the with the normandy
forum and our consultation with partners
kiev is not implementing the minsk
agreement and is categorically against
um having direct dialogue with the
leadership of donbass and lukansk and is
subverting
uh the
commitments to provide donbass with
special status and
the amnesty which are key to the
agreements uh human rights are
systematically violated in ukraine uh
the discrimination of russian's
population is
violent is
proceeding at the legislative level
uh efforts to d
uh to reduce tension
are
con
depends on the implementation of the
minsk agreements
all kiev has to do is sit down at the
table with the representatives of
donbass and agree
political and humanitarian means to
settle the conflict and the sooner the
better unfortunately right now we are
observing
the contrary and escalation of the
situation in donbass in conclusion i
would like to express my thanks to mr
lukashenka
for our constructive work together and i
am certain that our talks today will
serve the strengthening of our bilateral
relations and tomorrow as we agreed
we will attend the planned
event concerning our joint military
activity
dear friends
our meeting today with
mr putin
is taking place
in the context of an unprecedented
escalation of military um
tension around the world as the
president said
given the
acute nature of the situation we spoke a
lot about this
issue and discussed our possible joint
actions in response to the aggression of
our
of western partners
i want to say again
nobody wants not even not just war but
any escalation of any conflict we don't
need that neither russians nor the
russians need it
those informed about these issues will
know that even our neighbors including
ukraine
are not the key players here
the key players you know who they are
the first time in decades we are on the
brink of a conflict unfortunately that
may suck in the whole continent
into the sinkhole
we can see the irresponsible
and even the lack of intelligence on the
part of certain
um narrow-mindedness of certain
politicians
and the unreasonable conduct of the
leaders of our neighboring countries
their
their painful decision to
walk
on the brink on the edge
mr putin spoke about the deplorable
situation in donbass people are ready to
flee and as we know they are already
fleeing that is not normal
i have the impression that certain
certain
people vested with the huge
responsibilities
the politicians of the so-called free
world
are pathologically dangerous
to those around them including their own
people
just in the last few
in in the next few days the joint drill
allied resolve of russian belarus will
finish tomorrow mr putin and i will
attend
a joint um exercise in the russian
federation which the media will be
informed about
and
as regards the exercise complete
completing and the
president has already mentioned it in
the face of a growing military danger on
our borders and the pumping of ukraine
with weapons
belarus and russia are forced to find
adequate means of
of fighting off the aggress aggressor on
our southern borders as far as belarus
is concerned and there is no surprise
that we are watching this
over 1 000 kilometers of the southern
border and we're looking for points
where we would have to conduct our
defense
the russian federation and i have a
joint
defense system and a
joint army
joint training centers
and the military doctrine of the union
state
all these documents and plans
have never been hidden
mr putin was very open about it and
everybody knows so the exercise
is our joint decision that is based on
the situation at hand it is very
transparent it's on our land
and we do not hide this from anyone it
is happening under the
um
under the watchful eye of the entire
army of military attaches and the press
of course we also discussed the
integration
of the union state
it has been four and a half months since
the decree of the
uh on the union state was signed which
was um which which enshrined the main
agreements to build the union state for
2022-23 including the 28 union programs
we are about 30
um ahead um
along the path of these programs
what has been done
what the progress is has already been
commented on a lot and the president has
mentioned this too
at the moment we're paying particular
attention on the
following areas customs
tax and the joint gas market
even
more
those those pursuing sanctions
will
suffer from them
will be the first to suffer
attempt to impose an economic war
against us
is going to cost us of course
we have already learned to
stand against the sanctions and the
trade turnover is between us is
proof of that but we have to spend a lot
of resources on countering the sanctions
pressure and we talked a lot about it
and i i appreciate mr president's orders
that you have given
to the leadership of the russian
federation
in my presence
i'm very grateful to you for that
but the fact that we belong russians and
russians will
emerge from this hybrid war
successfully that is clear our
cooperation in the economy has
strengthened and bilateral trade has
seen many new product lines
and
the way our
external trade is diversifying
the world is large you can't lock up
every door and every transport route
another
area we discussed was the economy
and it is pleasing that we worked well
last year despite various pandemics and
viruses
we grew our
trade turnover to almost 40 billion and
that's something we can count
there is no border
here and
these are billions of dollars and the
both economies grew both in gdp
and in industrial output
and in many other areas of the real
sector of the economy
of course we all talked more about
problems than successes
they are getting fewer but they still
remain
we discussed support measures for the
economy strengthening financial
stability
uh
increasing business and cooperation
of course i informed the president of
russia how belarus is preparing for the
important political event the
constitutional referendum and we shall
hold it in dignity in the interests of
the russian people and it will not be
counter to
our relationship without brotherly
russia the west using
the hands of
our enemies is trying to
rock the boat in belarus however nobody
is having any delusions about repeating
the august of 2020.
this is important
this is strengthening our confidence
that together we will overcome any
um situation and any challenge and build
our common future
and
nobody should expect that we will
somehow
shiver in front of in the face of
problems
i will repeat we don't want a war
but if somebody can't wait to have one
our response
will be asymmetrical
i think everybody in the world
understands that
and
by defending
the security of our nations and our
states
we shall act
appropriately
mr putin said and i agree with him we
are trying to
they're trying to
cast a wedge between us not only just us
too but also any other countries that
are trying to
to unite
kazakhstan is proof of that
and we appreciate that thank you very
much
okay that was the bala russian president
alexander lukashenko as well as the
russian president vladimir putin who
have both been holding meetings today in
moscow luka shenka has said he never
discussed any attack on ukraine with
putin and this comes as lukashenko has
said he would take part in overseeing
military drills on saturday along with
the russian president to break this all
down for us let's bring in dorsa jabari
in moscow hello there dorsa pujan has
said that these military drills are not
a threat to any other country what else
did you take out of that
well he made it very clear um during
this press conference following a nearly
two-hour meeting with his uh bella
russian counterpart alexander lukashenko
putin said that these are collective
measures these military drills that have
been ongoing since february
early february between the two countries
he said that they are to strengthen the
country's securities and their
capabilities their defensive case
capabilities and he said the drills that
have been named allied resolve
are totally defensive in nature and all
the relevant parties
in the area were informed well in
advance so there is no reason for this
hysteria that's been created by these
war games that have been ongoing and
they will come to an end on february
20th that is sunday the um russian
president also seemingly very happy to
stress the strong relationship he has
with
belarus and the president from there he
said that
they will they share the same um
ideas that nato's expansion is very much
a threat not only to russia but also
belarus he said that um also despite the
fact that the security guarantees have
not really uh been answered by the west
and the u.s the vladimir putin said that
we're still willing to continue the path
of diplomacy he also said that there is
a
deplorable situation ongoing in donbass
in eastern ukraine where he has in the
past said there is accused the ukrainian
government of carrying out genocide
that is something that he's still
mentioning every time he speaks with any
world leader he brings that up as well i
think it's important we also heard some
very strong words from alexander
lukashenko who said that apologies we're
going to have to interrupt you now
because they're just holding a conflict
press conference at the moment with some
questions and answers so we'll cross
back to you as soon as we can that was
dawson jabari in moscow this is vladimir
putin and his counterpart from
belarussia answering answering some
questions
there it is zero chance to break the
belarusian people
and they will become
even
um more negative
they will not succeed
when they say that there's a
dictatorship that we are prosecuting by
the russians
that that's a fairy tale
nobody is prosecuting anyone
we're simply responding to attempts at a
coup in organizing a coup in belarus
just as they said just that they did it
in ukraine they wanted to replay that in
belarus but they did not succeed
that's why i mentioned kazakhstan
my question to both of you you mentioned
the sanctions war that was started
against you and against us and we see
that the pressure is growing steadily
and the latest
in that was
the ban on fertilizers
um russia is being threatened with
prevent unprecedented sanctions um mr
lukashenko you said um there has been a
series of
instructions
from the presidents what do you see
as anti-sanction measures and
we men mentioned that as part of
integration and as part of cooperation
what is the cooperation between russia
and belarus in against sanctions and who
can help us here
we must help ourselves
that's what our meeting was about
most this was in the focus of our
attention
and mr lukashenko mentioned this is
these are economic uh issues issues of
economic cooperation um mr
lukashenko said very colorfully you
can't lock up every route the world is
large and i join his assessment
we discuss the whole range of issues
including
the one you mentioned i'm not going into
detail on this but there are solutions
as far as where we should be moving as a
whole i want to stress
that this
sanctions pressure first of all is it's
unlawful it is a gross violation of
international law
and those talking about it they only
care about international law when it
suits them when it doesn't suit them
they're happy to forget
any
norms of international public law we
understand this very clearly we have
been living in this paradigm for many
years because those
in power as they think
they are the masters of life
they're always interpret everything to
their benefit
and they ignore the interests of others
but
the path of overcoming the situation
is to strengthen our own potential and
first of all in the economic
sector
sanctions will be introduced one way or
another whether they have a pretext
today to do with events in ukraine or no
pretext they will find one because their
aim is different their aim is to slow
down the development of russia in this
case and of belarus
this
aim will always be served
by introducing the some kind of
restrictions and this is nothing but
um
unlawful
competition
unfair competition russia has done a lot
in this area and lately and this is
import substitution
we have not been able to do everything
we planned but 90
um we have been
we have completed the tasks that we set
for ourselves we have lots to do yet and
this is about
increasing our economic sovereignty
many countries in the world
uh are in
even allies of the us are experiencing
restrictions but they keep silent
they put up with it
but as i said many years ago
nobody likes it nobody likes secondary
sanctions nobody likes direct pressure
of sanctions
sooner or later this boil will burst
today it is important for us to
increase our economic sovereignty
and to become more effective
become more
modern
in developing
the
modern um state-of-the-art sectors of
the economy this is digitization
artificial intelligence genetics this is
a complex piece of work we won't solve
it today but we should move in that
direction and the integration processes
that we're dealing with are devoted to
this
the task of increasing our competitive
edge
and we will
raise living standards as part of that
and
that's that's um
that's the summary of it that i could
tell you at the press conference the
nature
the essence of our talks
most of it was devoted to sanctions and
the economy as the president said the
essence is that whatever we do
however hard we try
to do something um even though we focus
mainly on our own interests
they will always find the pretext
to
escalate this economic war this is not
sanctions this is an economic war
unleashed on our union
and that's that's the essence as for
details
we did talk about the details
especially
as you uh you
you mentioned
potassium fertilizers mr putin ordered
directly we we said we need a port
in violation of international agreements
we have been blocked from the roots
where we used to work
and you can't do that
if a country has no access to the sea
nobody can block the transport route to
see
russia does have
access to sea and it isn't blocking
anybody latvia lithuania and ukraine
have access
but they blocked our access
and the west and
i'm just recalling
what's happened
the president of russia at my request i
asked so that we have no bureaucracy no
red tape it's not a question of money we
have the money well we would like
uh to have to build a terminal near st
petersburg
and process millions of tons of cargo
there
and while i was there
orders were issued to begin this
construction immediately
and we will
in a year or a year and a half the
ambassador is here he knows
we will
um transport this cargo there
well
lithuania
formed the whole lithuanian budget
is it's 30 our transit we're not going
if we leave lithuania and ukraine we
won't go back
as
they said whatever as mr president said
whatever
sanctions it's a question of opportunity
and this is
it's it's
this is about import substitution areas
for us belarussians
the most modern state-of-the-art
technology we can do anything
we have shown this
who
was the first to produce a vaccine
russia did
russia supplied it to belarus
and
almost two and a half million vaccine
doses have been already produced in
belarus and we're creating our own um
we're designing our own technology and
we will solve other issues as well
thank you very much
can we go please metri thanks
okay
okay that was vladimir putin and
lucas sench lucas lukashenko rather
in speaking in moscow let's get some
analysis now on this and bring in
richard witts who's a defense analyst
and joins us live from washington thanks
for being on the program richard there
are lots of moving parts to this story
and i want to sort of break it down
first i want to start with this most
recent press conference between the
russian and belarusian presidents talk
us through the significance of this
relationship between the two men
well the relationship has been troubled
for decades
uh in as many uh see lukashenkos had
have having had aspirations to lead
the russia
uh
belarusian
union state they have a created a common
state with some federal institutions
it's not that tightly bound but at
various points in history there were
ideas to bring them closer
and in the early 1990s this was taking
place
you know luthershenko was a senior
politician
putin was a nobody and he came on the
scene and there was a lot of rivalry
initially
um and since then
belarus has been a difficult partner for
russia constantly haggling over the
price of gas
constantly criticizing various russian
policies but of course all this changed
after the failed presidential election
in which
the you know lucasfilm lost
there was a lot of calls throughout the
world for his removal
but russia stood by him and i think at
this point he's
he's basically
subservient to russia
uh pretty much follows the russian line
and everything he he did not recognize
the annexation of crimea for example
earlier he now does
so
he's become very pliable and i would
think the russians would love to have
that kind of relationship with whoever
leads ukraine
uh richard putin has said during that
press conference that military drills
with belarus are not a threat to any
other country so why is the us nato and
their allies thinking any different
uh because his interpretation uh as is
incorrect for air to be nice
if he the russian armed forces are
holding their large largest drill their
largest concentration of forces
uh in decades
and they're surrounding ukraine by three
sides as we've seen in your show on the
north through belarus through the center
of russia and then from the south
and
they've taken many steps that make that
what you would do if you were prepared
to launch an invasion
so it's
they certainly have the option to invade
at any time
the
they clearly want to us whatever they
say to think there might be an invasion
so they can exploit that to gain
concessions from the west concessions
from ukraine so this is why the west is
upset
the other issue that's unfolded this
afternoon is that we've received reports
that russian-backed separatists in
eastern ukraine plan to evacuate
residents in this breakaway region now
this really is a stunning turn in this
conflict and is it further adding fuel
to the fire which the west says is
moscow trying to justify an invasion a
pretext to wall
right so it's interesting because if
they wanted to justify you would maybe
want to keep the civilians there and
just make sure some of them are killed
uh and that would justify the russian
intervention but withdrawing uh
civilians is normally a prelude to uh
initiation of hostilities uh you want to
remove your own non-combatants from
potential combat zone to minimize their
casualties so to get them off the roads
for example you don't have refugees on
the roads that would interfere with your
troop movements
so it could be seen as a prelude to an
offensive
uh
by making the cost of any offensive to
russia and the separatists lower in
terms of civilian lives
just as an aside for example though many
criticized the western withdrawal from
afghanistan because it failed to
withdraw
their civilians before the military left
and it's supposed to be the other way
around you basically get rid of get the
civilians out of the combat scene and
then you engage in combat operations
another major line that's been breaking
today is u.s defense secretary lloyd
austin visiting warsaw or in poland and
announcing a deal to sell 250 battle
tanks to poland obviously the details
are yet to be worked through
what's the significance of that
relationship poland now with the us in
the context of what's happening in
ukraine
sure any other day you know what any
other year i would say
there wouldn't be too much attention
poland has been making major purchases
of russian of u.s
military equipment for years they've
done
they've bought some advanced
networking sets and control systems
ways to link your soldiers with air
force and missiles from us army
they bought u.s warplanes they bought
trains you remember president
trump was talking about at various
points taking troops out of germany
moving into poland
so there's a strong very strong defense
relationship between the two but coming
in the context of
a potential invasion by russia of
ukraine it clearly it has an added
emphasis of trying to communicate to
russia as well as reassure polls that
the u.s will support them
in any conflict with russia
well we appreciate you breaking it all
down for us with what is quite a complex
story that's richard witt a defense
analyst out of washington dc thanks for
being on the program
thanks for having me